it's not salty it's not have you ever
put a kiddy corn I'm a mom ever but I
don't want to put it in my mouth I don't
think he has cuz he doesn't even know
what it is boo just kiddin
candy corn the sweet Harold of spooky
times to come or a seasonal blight it's
debatable
I'm Pro candy corn because I have joy in
my life and I'm against candy corn I
think Katie corn is the bomb I think
candy corn sucks candy corn is the
dumbest candy candy corn is the most fun
candy oh god what do I even love about
candy corn
exactly candy corn is the perfect
holiday treat it's the first thing that
you see that you're like ah fall is here
well that's because my opponent is
living in California being ignorant to
the rest of the world I think you could
have Katie chords or sitting out for
three months and it'd still be okay
that's not the sign of a good candy do
you even dress up on Halloween yeah
what is this costume this is it I wear
costume to this debate cuz you're not
fun but I am and so is candy corn it's
got a very distinct look you can say
that about any candy bread really M&Ms
skittles they look exactly the same if I
gave you a bowl of M&Ms and skittles
right here you would reach in eat
something be like you candy corn is so
special the only once a year it shows up
to bring joy into the lives of children
chocolate is lying to everyone it's like
oh I'm a Halloween chocolate I'm a
Christmas chowder a penis isn't trying
to pretend to be a great chocolate you
can euro fun with her look at perfect
north the phone you know Americans eat 9
billion pieces of candy corn every year
maybe 32 million pieces of candy corn
are thrown away that's not even a big
number out of 1 billion
what about candy corn is so horrific
that it has to go
it's just Oh millions of people like it
millions of people have fun when they
have candy corn on Halloween every year
that's terrible have you ever had a
debate before Michelle
the fact is that you can spend your time
doing something better if you're trying
to eat candy you can get better candy
it's like eating a candle an edible
candle you're telling me you wouldn't
eat that no I think that'd be a fire
what do you think is worse than candy
corn like literally nothing wait
literally nothing exactly it's the
bottom of the barrel kids are crying all
over America who get candy corn in their
bags and where are your scientific poles
I surveyed the group of kids that I
trick-or-treated with growing up did you
know them before him yeah of course we
did that's a sourcing issue she's
sourcing her data it's a candy modeled
after a vegetable you realize that right
you know how many jobs there are in this
country because people produce corn you
saying you don't like farmers no I love
corn I just don't think it needs a candy
tribute okay you want me to eat it look
I'll eat Wow it's like eating Indian
clay I do have a little bit thicker it's
a making uses not
haters are going to continue to hate no
matter what anybody who ends a debate
with haters gonna hate or that's just
your opinion has obviously lost the
debate final thoughts candy corn is the
perfect seasonal candy you are doing the
perfect season a complete disservice
candy corn much like to be sick I've
throttled my opponents so heavily she's
come up with a closing statement
walk into the club like gee and you're
like [ __ ] it's Halloween
what's happening can you throw Snickers
in the air no you make it rain how that
you see I've been injured